now I think most of you are doing okay
on the leftmost part and the rightmost
part because it feels quite similar to
what we were doing in the first graph
right you're like oh I'm getting bigger
and bigger so that means I get smaller
so you get this kind of shape sort of
goings you you know getting really
really little like that and then just to
the left you can see in here because
you're getting smaller on the original
what happens to the reciprocal it gets
bigger right its skyrocket so that's why
you can see oh yeah I have a vertical
asymptote right there that's exactly
what I should expect right and the same
thing happens in Reverse on the left
hand side like so so this is the shape
and I think people are pretty content
that that's what's happening on the
outside the inside part between negative
2 and negative 3 that's the bit that's
weirder okay now let me just throw an
idea at you right suppose from this X
here right suppose I go up I decide I
want my graph to go up just I'm just
guessing right now my clue sorry my
question to you is where is it going to
go from here and the answer is there's
got no way to go right it's like I can't
break through here because that's a
vertical asymptote it's like that's the
place where my calculator breaks it
certainly can't go any higher because
remember we shaded the reciprocal of a
negative is negative as well right so
going up turns out to be a really crummy
option right the only other option is to
go down and that shouldn't surprise us
because just look closely in here I can
cheat here because I've got the screen
right see this is negative 1/4 right and
so we took its reciprocal we got
negative 4 right but then as we go
toward the right here see how these
values are getting teeny teeny tiny
right like zero point negative zero
point 1 negative zero point zero 1 and
so on
yeah because the original is getting
smaller the reciprocal is getting bigger
but negative bigger but negative okay so
that's why this shape that you get down
here it just drops like a rock like so
ok it's kind of like a parabola but
there's an important difference it's not
a parabola here's why this this original
shape here this is a parabola right can
someone tell me
where can I put a vertical line where
the parabola stops where was it well
let's stop well on my graph it stops
like there but I could keep going
couldn't I is there a place I can put
this vertical line so it's like there no
further no you can't because thing about
domain right
the domain of this guy is all real
values of X you can go forever right now
compare that to this shape here see this
guy here it's like you know who's
watching all of the Rings right this is
Gandalf you shall not pass you can't go
any further
that is fundamentally different to a
parabola right it stops it's got a limit
okay make sense okay now put your pens
down for a minute and look up let's um
let's draw some summary points from both
of these okay for example you notice
here right we just drew the shape I
didn't ask you to worry about the sign
positive negative but then we noticed
that afterwards right we're like oh
that's kind of nice there's a similar
thing that we can observe about both of
these but it's not about the sign it's
about the symmetry do you notice this
parabola right every parabola is
symmetrical yeah it has a line of
symmetry right the parabola the original
has symmetry look at the reciprocal the
blue graph do you notice it also has
symmetry right that shouldn't surprise
us because if you take the reciprocal of
things over here and they're exactly the
same as the values over here then
symmetry like this in the original gives
you symmetry in the reciprocal so you
know how we wrote this the sign of the
reciprocal matches the sign the original
we can say this again sorry I'm gonna be
really cheap you can't do this but I'm
gonna do it anyway it's not just the
sign of the original that matches the
reciprocal it is the symmetry right so
if you have a line of symmetry in your
original function then you will have a
line of symmetry in your reciprocal
function in fact have a look at the
first function have a look at this one
now you know how you're like mr. woo
that's cheating you can just copy and
paste stuff okay
I'm about to ask you to do something
that you can do but I cannot okay
actually no I think I can
I want you to take your page and I want
you to go away there we go I want you to
rotate your page now how do I do this on
here I think I can yeah
technology if I had to sunder a
visualizer okay here we go alright this
is what I'm talking about yeah that's
what I've got all right have a look at
that can you turn your page 45 degrees
turn your page 45 degrees should look
like this right now look at the original
function in the way that we've arranged
it that original function right now it
looks like a horizontal line doesn't it
right so it's symmetrical isn't it like
you could flip that horizontal line over
be the sack the exact same thing okay
well this symmetry here gives you a
symmetry look at this hyperbola right
did you ever notice that the hyperbola
has a line of symmetry it's just it's
sort of offered an angle right so the
symmetry of the original gives us this
symmetry of the reciprocal okay another
way we can say this is let's go back to
this guy right this line here it has
point symmetry that's rotational
symmetry right so you can take this guy
can I ask you now you need rotated 45
degrees can you rotate all the way a
hundred and eighty degrees turn your
page upside down right now if you turn
your page upside down what you'll notice
is hold on a second that is exactly the
same shape I'm gonna do it here I know I
kind only knows we go that far
technology is it all that is there yeah
I got to do that thing right there we go
there we go okay you're like oh it's the
same guy right that rotational symmetry
in the original there it is gives you a
rotational symmetry in the reciprocal
are you with me so far my brain is
melting okay let's come back now what
have we got you can look at the sign
positive negative you can look at the
symmetry and then you can look for these
particular values what happens to the
values I'm not going to hold your hand
with this one at all turn the page have
a look at this what do you think this is
by the way that's a cubic okay you don't
need to know the equation I can give you
the equation in a minute so you can test
out with desmos but I want you to use
all this knowledge we've developed think
about this
sign think about where this thing is
positive or negative think about does it
have any kind of symmetry I can take
advantage off and lastly I want you to
think about where are the important
values that I can use where's y equals
zero
where's y equals one where's y equals
negative one look for those points put
them onto the page see if I can get off
you go